you're going back to school says
meatball
new york schools can reopen cuomo says
in contrast with much of us
we all know governor cuomo i
affectionately
call him meatball and we know his
brother
chris uh fredo cuomo corleone
who was offended at the name fredo he
thought it was a slur against italian
americans so now we call him chris
uh uh fredo cuomo corleone
and uh we remember and we forgive him
for his lie that he had coronavirus and
beat it by
chest exercises remember that when chris
cuomo had coronavirus and beat it by
going like this
that's how we beat it so we apparently
shut down the economy
for something that you can beat by just
stretching your chest
in the living room of your home so we
forgive him for his lie
okay like uh like we would do we would
say
what's that line in the godfather uh
which one
uh i don't know he's disappointed in the
kid
is that the godfather i don't know what
you're talking about where he's like uh
i don't know doesn't he look at fredo
and he was fredo you
you disappoint me or something what's
that famous line
i know it was you fredo that was that
was you know
oh yeah yeah here it is i know it was
you fredo
here you go up there you broke my heart
you broke my arm you broke my heart you
broke my heart when you're lying about
having coronavirus and that you beat it
by doing
chest exercises but we forgave you your
family that's fine
um uh meatball has decided that the kids
are going back to school
and cases in new york are very low and
people are just gonna get back to the
business
uh of you know uh bringing the kids into
new york city schools
and um you know not educating them but
so we're happy about that
and the teachers are a lot of the
teachers are not happy
a lot of the teachers are upset um
um but let's be very honest here and i
get flack for this a lot but i don't shy
away from controversial opinions
let's be very honest have you
ever and some of the people listening
are are going to not like this
have you ever met a teacher that wasn't
just a little bit of a self-important
[ __ ]
i'm speaking of the female teachers the
male teachers we all know are just
pedophiles
any of them very agreeable though and
friendly i mean they have to be they're
you know they [ __ ] the kids
but i mean female teachers many times
are self-important for lack of a better
word
see you next tuesdays it's just what
they are
they spend their entire lives with
children they talk to you
like you or a child teaching is not the
job it was when my grandmother did it
when you didn't get paid to do it
and it was you had a genuine uh passion
for
teaching children now it is
a job that a lot of people take
because it pays very well in a lot of
suburban areas
and also they get the two prime months
of the year off
so i i've likened them
to summer enthusiasts that's what i call
a lot of teachers
summer enthusiasts okay they show up at
7 30 in the morning they hand out some
folders you're out by 2 30 every day oh
no they don't
they don't leave at 2 30. they they stay
for chefs
club great
great okay now not all teachers are bad
okay not all teachers are bad
but if we're gonna broad brush cops
if we're gonna paint with a broad brush
let's
paint you know what i mean and a lot of
teachers
these social interactions you have with
them you dread them they start
explaining
things to you like you need to explain
[ __ ] i'm not nine
i know what the supreme court is pipe
down okay
teaching's the most important job in the
world it is not the most important job
in the world
the the america is so behind
in every educational standard and all we
do is praise
teachers the statistics are much worse
for teachers than for cops much
worse yes or yes
where is american reading and math
let's find it out right now
if cops were shooting as many people as
teachers were
failing it would be a cause to abolish
them
and this is not all teachers and i don't
want people that
are teachers to get angry with me i want
you to grow up and take a little
criticism
okay from a comedian someone who really
knows the ins and outs
i have a value in society unlike you
showing up to a [ __ ] let's try to
find where we are in math and reading
this is from october 2019 okay
math and reading scores for fourth and
eighth graders in the united states
dropped and the decrease in reading
achievement has government
researchers particularly concerned over
the past decade
there has been no progress in either
mathematic or reading performance
and the lowest performing students are
doing worse
okay that's the reality
i i don't know how to i mean find find
the statistics i know it's tough
but try to find them because i it's
really an important point that i'm
making here
if we're going to say abolish cops why
not abolish teachers
i'm dead serious here let's abolish
teachers
if you think people can walk around
society and police themselves
kids can teach themselves let's have a
school with no teachers
okay no new toyota camry's pulling up
they get out with their latte
i will get so much hate for this and i
don't care
because i've had a i know a lot of
teachers my aunt is a teacher i respect
her
my grandmother is a teacher and i
respect her i'm this is not going at all
teachers but we all know
there's a lot of bad teachers and the
good teachers stay silent about it
the good teachers stay silent about the
bad ones
i went to a catholic school we had
teachers that used to make out with the
kids in the hallway
and those were the good teachers
those are the ones who stayed after
class and ran clubs and cared
they helped you fill out your college
application sure they goosed ya
sure every now and then they they wanted
your phone number and they wanted to
take you on a date
after school but that's nice we did we
had a teacher
who was a theater teacher who just was
like making out with a girl in the
hallway holy trinity diocesan
hicksville if you know you know
i'm not trying to get sued
i have a friend whose wife's a teacher i
mean it's like i mean they're just they
just
show up and they just tell you
they talk to you like you're a child and
i'm just saying
so the problem is a lot of them are
going to be upset they feel like they're
being put in an unnecessary risk
maybe some of them are but
if meatball wants the kids to go back to
school
the kids are going to go back to school
that's what's going to happen
and as a teacher you want to educate the
kids and you're passionate about it
you're going to have to take a little
bit of a chance and i
i don't say that lightly oh
tim you get to work alone you don't have
to be around anybody
yes i do yes i do
okay i'm sorry that i chose the
profession i chose
i went 10 years without making a dollar
i worked on a tour bus
i tried to sell photocopiers over the
phone you went to a school
you got a degree you got an education
you have all the financial security
pretty much that you can ask for
not always but a lot of the times
especially these teachers that teach in
the burbs
and you know okay world's best education
systems
they're saying that we're number two
that's not true all of them are finding
are saying we're number one or two this
is that's not gonna be
right no this is this this is the
teachers are running this
this is not true this feels all fake
everything i click on says everything
the kid the kids can't read out there
the kids are on they're they take all
these pills they're black-eyed nihilists
the kids
we we did the video with the kids yeah
and that little kid oliver in there he's
a black-eyed nihilist
he literally believes in nothing the
children they think nothing matters and
they're right
u.s we're gonna have to get back to you
with these [ __ ] statistics
our fans will go and find them if we're
125 on a list of 197 countries in terms
of literacy how do we have the best
education system
you can't get the right answers here
anymore
nobody's giving you the right answers
we're not the best education system in
the country
i mean that's crazy it's crazy we're not
most of these teachers don't even know
the three branches of government
go ask a teacher what the three branches
of government are in a public school
they're gonna say the fire department as
one of them
okay i found one that this is usually
where we are yeah we're 20th we're 20th
behind
finland japan south korea denmark russia
norway united kingdom israel sweden hong
kong netherlands belgium
germany china singapore portugal hungary
estonia france
and then the united states of america
so the answer is put the kids back in
school trim the fat
that's the reality some of the teachers
aren't gonna make it i feel bad about
that the world is not perfect
we could all die tomorrow i could die
tomorrow and then all you'd be left with
is these brilliant archives of a
misunderstood genius okay
but but meatball has spoken
and he said that there is no economy
without the kids in schools
there is no economy without the children
going back to school
so that their parents can can stop
pretending to care about them
one of the biggest impediments to
putting
the economy back together is kids are
running around the streets right now
filming tick tocks and taking drugs and
what needs to happen is they need to go
back into school
where they could be in a social
environment and have teachers
watch them and attempt to educate them
okay that's what we need so that their
parents can go back
to work that's what needs to happen
we're not able to do anything unless the
kids are in school
so yeah a lot of teachers are gonna come
down on me go you don't know what a hard
job it is
you don't know how tough it is yeah
you're right i don't
you're right i am okay
i will t i have all i will teach
but it's got to be what i want i'm not
going to teach the common core
curriculum
that meatball and his brother want i
will teach
i will teach different classes what
about a class called 911 a closer look
with mr dylan
i'll do it okay
but i'm not gonna teach this uh
horseshoe here's a scarlet letter read
the scarlet letter
what hey rita tales of fourth grade
nothing
no we're not doing that
we will spend the semester investigating
the attacks of 9 11.
and you'll go home every day and tell
your parents what you've learned